all right
all right welcome to the ddk seminar
everyone uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you're welcome to mute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in Q a session at the end second
today's gdps seminar is open to external
audiences
so no classified discussion is allowed
finally The Talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today it is an honor to host the
handsome bye bye who is currently on a
assistant professor in the department of
mechanical engineering and Material
Science at the University of Pittsburgh
he earned his PhD in mechanical
engineering and math Masters in Applied
Mathematics both from Louisiana State
University in 2013. he then joined the
mechanical engineering department at MIT
for his postdoctoral research where he
worked with Professor George kanyadakis
he joined the University of Pittsburgh
in January 2017.
his research is focused on developing
videos to the model
and the Machine learning techniques for
Science and Engineering problems his
research has been funded by many
organizations including NASA NSF and NIH
and the air force of scientific research
today has some will talk about
occur Matrix decomposition for scalable
reduced Auto modeling of non-linear
partial differential equations using
time dependent basis
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further Ado let me pass the
button to Hassan by asking one random
questions today's random question is
what is your idea of the perfect day
what defines your perfect day
okay perfect day would be a sunny day by
the beach with my family oh nice right
now in California it's not a perfect day
neither is is here okay stage is yours
all right okay thank you so much Yang
Soo for the invitation and your kind the
introduction uh so as you said I have
been working on on developing reducible
modeling based on time dependent basis
so to just motivate that and and so let
me play this animation but you'll see on
the left is a biologically reacting flow
uh these are you're seeing this species
mass production of 23 species here
and in order to solve this equation you
have to solve basically a system of PD
of 23 equations and uh so uh you can
have larger mechanisms and you can go up
to order of a thousand species which I
cannot show here obviously solving this
system of videos is computationally
expensive both in terms of memory uh IO
and also flop CPU cost right so a
floating Point operation cost so but as
as you saw let me play that again you
can see there is a lot of similarities
so as we say correlations between these
different species instantaneously and
what I want to show you that you can use
some independent basis to both extract
and also exploit these structures to
reduce the computational cost of this
this these simulations both in terms of
memory storage and what I want to talk
about which is the the focus of the talk
is the cor decomposition which I I can
show you that that kind of decomposition
can improve the flops cost so uh without
further Ado let me just go so these are
uh this is these are all my students and
collaborators these are the ones who
actually contributed uh to some extent
to this talk so I have my post stocks
for my postdocs and students and also my
collaborators Dr Prem and give you at
University of Pittsburgh Dr Jackie Chan
at Sandia Dr Mark Carpenter at Nasa
Langley and also Professor David
Fernandez at the University of Laurel
all right so this is an outline of white
talks I'll I'll just introduce this time
dependent basis uh I'll talk about some
of the previous stuff that we did and
application of time dependent basis to
competing sensitivities and also
turbulent combustion then I'll talk
about this uh CR factorization and how
that can be used
to speed up computation using this time
dependent basis and I'll talk about some
applications to answer the
quantification so let me just give you a
brief overview of of on the flight low
rank approximation using time dependent
basis
really the motivation is solving High
dimensional PDS even in the car when I
say high dimensional means if you
descriptase that system the discrete
Vector has a very large number order of
millions to billions and so the way we
solve this system of equations using
traditional scientific Computing
techniques we use this
um
basis we use them we choose them from
classical techniques it could be Fourier
methods could be polynomial methods
polynomial spectral polynomials uh so on
and so forth what we make a choice here
and then we do separation of values this
is like a traditional way of doing
scientific Computing and actually that
choice is is the core is the root of the
problems especially if we go to High
Dimensions where the these bases because
they do not ex exploit correlations then
then the computation resulting from this
kind of discretization suffers from the
curse of dimensionality meaning this and
scales
exponentially large with the number of
dimensions
so there are a number of ways to to
tackle this so one way is to do data
driven so let's gather data from this as
observative systems and then do some
sort of Dimension reduction
um
um you can do auto encoder uh you can do
pod DMD all kinds of uh
um Dimension reduction techniques and
then do some sort of projection so this
is a typical way of of solving this kind
of problem uh
but whenever we do any kind of data
driven
Dimension reduction
um there is no guarantee that whenever
we build that soft space or or manifold
that
um that manifold can extrapolate to to
unseen data right so you always have
that problem and also you have the issue
of actually having to solve that system
full or more right so it's for some of
these applications we can even solve
that full normal once let alone
generating data right so and like I said
the collectively and these are the
challenges of of adopting a data-driven
type methodologies for for these massive
systems so I'm talking about like 4K
applied type equation for example where
just solving these ones could be could
be out of a question
so the idea is to one way one remedy is
that that I've been focusing on is
actually to don't choose these spaces
let the governing equation find these
spaces for you in a way that exploits
correlation right so this is the whole
idea of of time dependent basis the in
an abstract way that we don't choose
this from a classical Library we
actually let the governing question to
find it and I'll show you how you can do
that for different problems okay so the
idea if I want to go back to the
uh challenges of that that you're going
to do so following is that can be
bypassed adapted generation and just
directly solve for these for these
equations right there are there is a way
to actually make these time dependent
basis also that treatment I'm not
talking about those uh those uh uh
problems today I'm focusing on the ones
that actually we don't want to do the
other generation we do want to directly
solve the PD so if you think about it we
just want to solve the pde by exploiting
the structure correlative structures in
the PD and and once we do that we can
actually build that reduce or more on
the Fly
so this is like a an overview of reducer
modeling with time dependent basis
very very important distinction between
these and like pod type decomposition is
that this is applied to Matrix
differential equations so you must have
a matrix you have to formulate your
problem as a matrix differential
equation and you can extend that to also
tensor differential equation let's say
this is the Matrix differential equation
number V is not a vector it's actually a
matrix so here I'm showing a schematic
of that let's imagine this space this
Matrix and it has many many columns you
can think of application of this as a uq
application but each column is is a
random sample of the of the dynamical
system and if there is this Matrix is is
instantaneously low rank you can
approximate it with an SVD approximation
this is just one scheme I check this as
an example
and if this is instantaneously low rank
you can reduce NS to R and hopefully R
if this is a low ranked Matrix R is much
smaller than n and then
basically this is an SVD like
decomposition
um within the time dependent uh reducer
modeling formulation you can actually
derive Evolution equation for all these
three components without actually
needing to generate data and these are
based on uh if you want to know the
background math behind this is actually
beautiful Romanian optimization uh where
this the rank or matrices uh you can
show that rank or Matrix realize the
space of rank or matrices realize that
this is smooth
manifold and then you can use that the
remaining optimization
tools to to do projection on that
manifold find the tangent space and
evolve that tangent space so all of the
math part I I'm not going to cover today
is actually in a cover within the
riemannian optimization but what's
important is that like I said there is
no data required here other than the
initial condition and boundary
conditions so yes that's data but not
observation of the physical ecosystem
right so and then you can derive
Evolution equation for for these
matrices
and because there is no data involved
right so you this kind of low rank
approximation doesn't even have the
issue of extrapolating to unseen data
because there is no data involved in the
whole workflow process so or adapt to
the changing conditions and one and one
of the nice thing about this kind of
decomposition is that the system could
be very high rank over time but needs to
be low rank instantaneously so that's
the key observation if the system is
very high rank instantaneously this is
not an efficient methodology
all right so because of connection to
SVD and I'll show you actually this is
very closely related to instantaneous
SVD of that Matrix and closely
approximates that without actually
Computing any SVD then that's the key
and it's quite interpretable right we
know how to interpret an SVD Dimension
reduction
uh just some some notes actually this
was originated in quantum chemistry
Community for solving Schrodinger
equation and so this goes back actually
in in the year 2000 there is this
beautiful review paper uh which shows
how this kind of methodology which you
you decompose your Matrix to three Rice
video like matrices
um that you can solve you can use that
for for solving sure they get equation
then in this paper this was uh put into
a more General context right so this is
exactly the same formulation here but
just put into more General context and
this is now called dynamic or low rank
approximation
uh and and sort of on an apparel
Universe uh another sort of
decomposition which is a a two Matrix
decomposition was also developed first
we know it's by temis sepsis and lemashu
at MIT they developed dynamically
orthogonal of the composition and and
later on uh georgakis and Tammy sapses
also worked together on this kind of
methodology and also myself and there
was another version of this again a two
matches decomposition biophenormal
decomposition it was shown that do and
Bo are exactly the same thing there's
also two two matrices decomposition
optimally time dependent decomposition
that is applied to linear systems which
I worked with uh I worked on that and
also there is a dynamically orthogonal
dually dynamical decompositions sorry
there's a typo here
what it's like this all of these
seminologists may sound confusing but I
want to show you that all of these are
actually equivalent to each other right
so actually we showed that in this paper
that you can uh that this dynamical low
rank approximation this triple matrices
are actually uh is like a hybrid of deal
and build together and they are
equivalent what do I mean by equivalent
they are exactly the same low ranked
Matrix approximation of the full Matrix
and so so as you see throughout this
talk I use uh s or or this but you
shouldn't get distracted by any of these
triple Matrix decomposition or two two
Matrix decomposition
what is important to know is that they
all follow the same principle and they
are equivalent okay let me show you an
example of that before I get to the cor
decomposition for computing
sensitivities how you can use this kind
of uh
um this is an application of of doing
videos Automotive based on time
dependent basis so this is applied to
compute sensitivities of of lot of of
high-dimensional systems right so if you
want to compute sensitivities of a high
dimensional system let's say this is a
non-linear dynamical system now you want
to perturb this with respect to some
sort of parameters for each of those
parameters you would have to solve this
linear sensitivity equation right so uh
obviously if the number of parameters is
large this is not a cost effective way
that's why people use adjoint equation
for adjunct equation you only saw one
equation backward in time so you have to
solve the forward equation and then
solve one equation backward in time and
and then compute sensitivities for a
given objective function with respect to
all the parameters but there is like two
major problems with that join one is
actually IO because you have to store
the full forward model and then and then
um to solve the action equation backward
in time so that I O is actually a a
major problem especially for massive
simulations like table and combustion
problems where you can store the forward
solution at all in a Time resolved
Manner and and also actually you have to
derive agent for any any given parameter
for any given objective function so if
your objective function changes you have
to do another iTunes equation but today
so now let's look at it from a a
completely different perspective and
that is that these sensitivities so if
you look at these sensitivities these
are actually different sensitivities
with respect to different parameters
they are correlated to each other
instantaneously if they are correlated
you don't need to solve for each one of
those and you can actually solve for a
compressed version of those forward data
right so that's really the key
observation here and so if you look at
this this is again you have a matrix
differential equation so you can look at
the sensitivity equation as a matrix
differential equation where you are
evolving all of these sensitivities
together and like I said if these are
low rank you can you can compress them
so
this is this work I was published last
year in Siam uh and this is I I'm using
the Dubai decomposition here like I said
you can actually derive at triple
decomposition here uh so instead of
solving for all of the sensitivity
software only a rank R would hopefully R
is much smaller than D solve for D so
you need to solve pde so this is not
cheap to solve either but at least you
solve pdes of order r instead of D and
then these are really projections of the
Polar model onto these bases and this is
you get these coefficients by wrong this
approximation if this Matrix is
instantaneously low rack it's a good
approximation and and that's it so the
way we swap we
um find the evolution equation for U and
Y is by forming a variational principle
this variational principle is nothing
but the residual that you get because we
are doing a low rank approximation so
instead of the whole Matrix of
sensitivity we put U by transpose in the
full or more and because is a low rank
approximation this is not going to be
zero but this is going to be some
non-zero we want to minimize this by
optimally updating the low rank basis U
and and the coefficient subject to this
orthonormative condition we want this uh
basis to be orthonormal you can actually
solve this with LaGrange multiplier once
you solve this equation you get this
close from Evolution equation for this
bases and the coefficients and then you
solve this instead of solving this
equation and that's where you get the
computational advantage right instead of
solving for D Fields you solve for R
fields
and and D over R is what you get in
terms of memory saving and also in terms
of in terms of flops
so this is now we apply this to a
H the same problem was showing you at
the very first slide this is the
biochemical reactions biological
reactions so these uh these are reaction
parameters and it is very important to
know how the any quantity of interest is
sensitive to any of these parameters
because the Computing is measuring these
quantities is very expensive and and you
you can't afford to measure all of them
super accurately you have to do a budget
allocation and say okay these 10
parameters are important and which are
those 10 parameters
there are other applications as well but
this is just one a skeletal model
reduction is another one so you can
actually drop these reactions if they
are not important if they're not if
nothing is sensitive with respect to
those and actually come up with the
reduced uh mechanism
so if you look at this this is actually
a tensor because you've got like here 23
species and you have 34 reaction
parameters if you look at the entire
Matrix the entire sensitivity is
actually a tensor
and you have parameters you have a
species here and then you have grid
points but so here what we do we flatten
this tensor and then it becomes a matrix
so these are the sensitivities of
different species with respect to
different parameters and then we seek to
approximate this with this low rank
approximation
so instead of solving 23 by 34 pdes
which would be forward sensitivity
equations or if you want to solve Adrian
equation you have to solve a natural
equation for each of these species so or
instead of solving 23 hydrogen equation
we want to do a low rank approximation
of this and see what we get now we did
that so this
particular formulation is called Force
optimal time dependent decomposition or
fotd and like I said it's a particular
variation of that time dependent basis
just applied to linear sensitivity
equation and you can see with increasing
rank from two to eight you can this is
relative error you can actually match
you can reduce the error significantly
like I said this is with with five mods
you can get less than one percent error
relative error and this is what we
optimal we show we actually took we
solved the full order model all of the
sensitivities and we took a continuous
SVD of that that would be the best and
lowest error that one could achieve and
we see actually we are tracking the
instantaneous SPD very well like I said
we when we solve these equations we do
not take any SVD this is all Evolution
equation but the evolution equation is
such that I approximate this
instantaneous SVD and you can see here
the singular values match with the S
instantaneous SVD so that means we are
actually very very closely tracking the
optimal Subspace here
and with five modes basically it's
equivalent the cost of solving for five
modes is equivalent solving five pdes
for five sensitivities as opposed to 782
and also memory storage is also the same
we saw basically we only need to store
five modes the coefficients those are in
terms of storing that those are
negligible and so but it can visualize
them can you go back to the previous
slide I've I don't usually stop the
presentation but I had to because I'm
I'm getting something so you're so
you're solving five pdes instead of 782
so
so from those five pdes you generate the
data and I mean but you said that you're
not using the data to construct these
evolutionary equations
I'm missing something how do you
actually construct so Evolution you saw
five videos for five of these modes and
also you solve an ode for the evolution
equation anytime you want you can
reconstruct the full order sensitivities
and I promise you simply just Matrix
Matrix so you saw for these two matrices
as shown here five PDS here the cost of
this is really negligible compared to
this so five PDS and ode which this is a
ROM basically but ROM is a instantaneous
projection of your Fuller model onto
this basis uh and and based on that you
can re Recon you can multiply these two
skinny matrices and reconstruct their
full sensitivities anytime you want but
we don't do that I mean but you can do
that at any any point you want and and
where are the where the parameter comes
in
um
parameters are the forcing they show up
by forcing in the sensitivity equation
right so when you take the linearized
sensitivity you take derivative of your
full hormone with respect to these
parameters the show of as forcing in the
right hand side of the nccf shows up in
all of these equations
okay
sure okay and also this actually be all
of the details you can find in this
paper if you are interested
and so let me go back to this slide so
you can see actually the modes here like
I said this is interpretable the modes
actually capture the structure so this
is the first mode the second one and
third one you see actually captures
finder and finance structures so these
are the time dependent Subspace that is
evolving with your system and like this
is a convection dominated problem so you
cannot solve these problems with pod
with static bases you have to resort to
some sort of basis adaptivity and I know
yongsu and also others actually have
worked on adaptive basis but this is a
matrix differential equation so I think
that's really the the difference here
not the vector Evolution equation and
also Benjamin pestrofer and Karthik also
the University of Michigan also have
worked on an Adaptive basis but uh but
this is like I said this is a matrix
differential equation anyway so once you
solve this problem you can actually take
your y one and and reconfigure that
because this we remember this was a
tensor we flattened that and then you
can actually see the sensitivities with
respect to uh of all the species with
respect to all 34 parameters this is
just one of the most y1 just visualize
here and you can see which parameters is
affecting which species immediately like
I said this is this actually has that
simplified data representation that is
immediately
it's explainable interpretable so I want
to talk about application turbulent
combustion this is another application
where you have a matrix differential
equation let's look at that so turbine
combustion you have to solve this
compressible now with six equation I'm
taking DNS here but this could be runs
or Les but then yeah you need to solve
this suspicious transport equation and
for complex views you may have even
order of a thousand species
so this is
solving this equation is really the
major cost of solving turbulent
combustion because you have to first
store this 1000 species which is really
just out of question four on the DNS
grid just storing a matrix with 1000
species is out of question and that is
really the main bottleneck and also the
i o cost like this is actually this is
from 2012 from Dr Jackie Chan's group
that uh simulate this is a direct quote
from the paper that because of IO
limitation you can we can only store
like for every 400 times above the
solution this is three-dimensional
simulation whereas there are things
happening or the order of 10 simulation
time is that that are completely missed
if you store the data every 400 times so
this is just i o so you can imagine the
memory and solving this system and this
is not for a 1000 species I think this
is order of 100 species so if as we push
this uh boundary to exit scale Computing
and especially when memory and I O are
the main issues actually solving this
equation is a major Challenge and so how
but if you look at this equation this is
a matrix differential equation a
non-linear Matrix differential equation
and again now here I'm using the triple
decomposition but like I said you
shouldn't get distracted by two
different by decomposition or triple
decomposition they are equivalent so
then you have this Matrix decomposition
you can write this so yeah this is a
full order model Evolution equation
again you can follow the same principle
which is a residual minimization plug in
this kind of low rank approximation and
this is a low rank approximation so
you've got some error here and plug it
in here because it's a low rank
approximation it's not going to satisfy
the full or more so you get this
residual you want to minimize that
residual by optimally updating all three
components once you solve this
minimization problem subject to the
other normality of U modes and Y modes
then you get Evolution equation here you
can find the details here in this paper
but just suffice to say that we are
solving this and solving this doesn't
require some optimize some iteration or
anything you get Evolution equation as
the optimality condition so the
evolution equations are the optimality
conditions so you don't need to solve a
non-linear optimization problem and so
on and so forth these are the optimality
conditions
so it's not like that you actually solve
a gradient base so these are actually
what minimizes if you if U and sigma and
what satisfy this governing equation you
are minimizing this residual
and so we apply this to uh different
fuels I'll just show you a sample of
this this is a two-dimensional Vlog uh
this is gri mechanism
actually has quite complex chemistry
it's got 53 species and 325 reactions so
this is a direct numerical simulation of
that we are showing Contours of
temperature and oh and this is a rank 6
approximation of this instead of solving
for 53 species we are solving for sixes
effective species and and and and so we
have done
more error analysis here I I just and
all those results are in this
paper that hopefully will be out soon uh
but I want to show you that like I said
for for practitioners these are this is
not just a way to speed up computation
this is actually interpretable so if you
focus on the Y modes here the Y modes uh
represent uh as a Time dependent
software space in the comp in the
thermal in the composition space right
so if you look at the composition this
place is a 53 dimensional space
and each of these vectors is is a so
this collectively is is a Subspace and I
can visualize that Subway space and also
we have done instantaneous PCA that
means instantaneous SVD of this Matrix
and be sure that this time dependent
basis actually uh closely followed uh
the the
um the instantaneous PC PCA but there is
also PCA that is done in combustion
Community unfortunately I don't have to
cover that but that's really equivalent
to like a pod approach but for
composition space so that's static you
can see uh that uh especially the higher
modes vary in time a lot
and you can look at the singular value
the singular values of that Matrix so we
solve the DNS of that and we computed
the singular values of that and then we
can see the singular values with this
low rank approximation we can capture
the leading modes very well
and these are
um so I want to go over this just in
inches of time but if you're interested
in this we have a lot more details in in
this manuscript and so we have extended
these two three-dimensional simulation
as well this is for a different
mechanism seeing gas mechanism it's
similar and you can see the modes the
now the modes here are three-dimensional
modes and this is a DNS uh mixture
fraction of DNS but these are the modes
one the first mode the second one third
more you can see the modes actually
evolve with the flow and they adapt to
the flow
this is another case done in Dr Jackie
Chan's group
um and and so this actually has a sudden
transition at the end so there's a
propagation of this wave from right to
left and then when it gets near the end
you will see a sudden transition in the
chemistry and so all the
this has a 39 species
and this is solved in s3d code with
eight order defined difference and all
these details are here let me just show
you uh this problem is actually very
high rank even in this mode so we had to
choose R equals to 29 so we are not
really getting so much
reduction here and this is actually I
want to show you this as one of the
challenges of solving these systems uh
that this instantaneously is not that
low rank but still you go from 39 to 29
you can see this that we can get that
transport but there's this sudden
transition at the end that this kind of
time dependent basis can capture that
certain transition and if you look at
and also this is a convection dominated
problem so this kind of reduce or more
in handles convection really well as I
mentioned earlier and if you look at the
the compositions of a space you see it
you will see at the end these two modes
drastically change in time the higher
modes usually change in time in in all
the cases that we have considered but
not the first two modes and you can see
at the end once this animation
approaches the end these are the two
most energetic modes and you can see
that that composition changes
drastically towards the end as you saw
here as a this is actually an extremely
challenging problem to solve all right
now I want to get to the cor
decomposition this was really an
introduction to this I wanted to talk
about some of the other challenges
especially how to solve this system of
equation efficiently for
for non-linear govern for non-linear
pdas right so if you look at the
evolution equation this is this is this
is this Evolution equation I showed in
the previous slide but just simplified
in terms of linear algebra right so you
solve an evolution equation for for
modes U and sigma and Y but but if the
right hand side of the Govern equation
is non-linear so this is the right hand
side of the governing equation you have
to compute this F which is a non-linear
map of your governing equation
if you form these Matrix first of all
you lose all the advantages that this
methodology has to offer because you
have to occupy the entire memory and
then apply this non-linear map on that
decompress Matrix even though when we
come back here we project it back to
this Subspace but this is the same
problem that exists in non-linear
reduce or more length with pod also we
have the same issue and this it is
exactly the same issue that shows up
here so you have you need to do some
sort of hyper reduction here and I want
to show you that cor is actually the way
to do hyper reduction here for this
Matrix differential equation
and so there are four issues with this
there is issue of cost which is the one
of your uh
um targeting here and also if you want
to get efficiency with solving this
equation if you're a governing equation
is non-linear like a combustion problem
or a uq problem
um if it is quadratic nonlinearity you
can get a speed up solving this equation
by just plugging in this expansion into
the governing equation and work out in a
painstaking way all the terms and and
solve this Evolution equation but that's
highly intrusive so you can get
efficiency for non-linear equation but
at the cost of doing an extremely
intrusive process those two these two
are really the major drawbacks of this
kind of formulation and so we wanted to
see if we can actually go back and and
be able to solve this system of equation
for a generic non-linearity but keeping
the cost the uh as low as solving just
for only R samples of this equation
right so our samples R is the rank of
the reduction that is the nominal cost
of solving this equation and also Rank
adaptivity and also stability when there
are two other issues with this system so
first of all R doesn't have to be fixed
right so the rank of a system evolves
over time so just fixing that that's a
problem so these problems actually uh
have been
um
this issue of inverting this Matrix have
been addressed in this beautiful work
by reformulating this problem uh to
another problem uh and actually
resolving this issue of having various
uh having to invert this Matrix this
matches could become ill-conditional
remember this is the singular value
Matrix and if you want to solve this
system with a high accuracy you need to
resolve very small singular values
and and so this is uh so you so you have
to be able to invert this Matrix this
integration and scheme actually resolves
that issue but the cost of
triple the cost of solving this the skin
propose here is triple of the cost of
two times as large as the cost of
solving this system but it doesn't have
this issue rank adaptivity also has been
proposed here with a work of Daniel 113
for tensor Revolution equation and also
within this formulation but not the
issue of course so these two issues have
not been addressed up to this point
and that's really I feel like these are
major
bottlenecks of solving this equation and
getting the scale that they can offer
okay so let me just go to
so the all the details here is in this
paper that was recently published by
myself and my my student Jose naderi uh
so let me just give you an overview so
here I'm switching to a uq problem
that's another application where you
actually a uq problem you can formulate
it as a matrix differential equation
here but all the samples are uh so if
you look at the uq problem you have a
non-linear
um differential equation and you have
some random parameters so this is the
Matrix of of all the samples where each
column is one sample and you want to do
a low rank approximation of these Matrix
like I said Computing this F of B is as
costly as solving the full order model
so that's the thing you want to work for
generic non-linearity if the system is
linear like the examples I showed at the
beginning you can actually work it out
and solve this system in the compressed
one and you can actually achieve all the
computational efficiency but not if this
system is non-linear and so
the cost of this system if you don't
handle this properly will scale with the
number of rows and number of columns of
this Matrix and that exactly the cost
that you want to what you want to have
this cost
so
um like I said for linear quadratic
system you can do that at the cost of
doing a highly intrusive process so the
question is how can we reduce the
computational cost of solving a rank or
tdb wrong time dependent basis wrong to
that of solving only to our samples of
that Fuller model that is the nominal
cost of evolving these equations
so
this is a uh so I want to explain cor
which is a really fantastic uh and I I
believe uh underexplored
linear algebra decomposition so this is
let me just explain that so let's say
you have a matrix G
and this Matrix has low rank structure
right so this you can approximately like
if you take SVD of this Matrix with rank
R you can approximate it well
you can actually get something super
close to an SVD of this matrix by
strategically sample The Columns and
rows of these Matrix all the blue ones
and all the all the red ones and then
you can approximate this this should be
an approximation but just The Columns of
this which are shown by blue color and
the rows of this Matrix which are shown
by red and this Matrix which is the the
intersection of these inverted
and this if you
um select these rows and columns
strategically you can get something very
close to an SVD and this was shown by
Sorensen and Embry uh that this is dying
induced cor decomposition
all right and so we adopted uh
the same strategy here uh in fact we
didn't know about this I have to confess
and we derived we developed this
methodology and later on we showed that
actually this is exactly cor
decomposition so instead of f of T is
the right hand side of the governing
equation so we can we only sample that
equation at these columns and rows not
that so anything you see here in gray
that is not computed and based on that
we can compute this uh you can also do
triple or or or or by the composition of
this message so we compute this by
sampling The Columns we find the column
space for we are to normalize that when
we we
denote that by V of T this is really QR
of the columns that we sampled and then
these are just the interpolation
coefficients that you can get it by the
by interpolating every other column of
this Matrix to these spaces so this is
an inter Matrix interpolation not a
matrix project not a matrix projection
and that is very important so there is
really nice uh connect this is actually
an oblique projection rather than
orthogonal projection so okay
unfortunately I don't have time to cover
all of that but the key is that remember
we didn't want to compute this Matrix
entirely we wanted to compute it only
that that was the cost right so but if
but this Matrix does have low ranking
structure it didn't have low ranking
structure we wouldn't be able to do this
time dependent basis to begin with
and so if it has low ranking structure
you can actually strategically sample
this the sampling strategy is based on
Direct empirical interpolation method
I'm not going to go over this all of
those details are in the paper how we do
this so we need to have SVD of this
message to Nowhere to sample we don't
have this Matrix to begin with let alone
the S video of this we use the previous
time step
uh SVD of the previous timer step of
this Matrix which we have it cheaply and
use those as as as to derive to tell us
where to sample right so that's and I
don't want to go over all of this but
all the details on that paper
um and so this is really an overview of
of this strategy like I said instead of
f the key is that instead of f now we
have two skin images that we can plug in
here so instead of putting F here
remember F was the source of all the all
the each computational issues now we
have a skinny factorization that is
plugged in here once you plug that in
here these are extremely fast then I
mean and also it's really nice that this
is actually relatively non-intrusive
because you only solve the Fuller Mall
you sample the Fuller mall and the right
hand side and this is the Strategic
columns and you only need to sample it
at these grid points these are different
grid points so this act you don't need
to derive a new set of equations for any
new pde you solve you can actually just
use it use this in fact there is a way
to extend this to even Black Box solver
and we are working on that and to make
this actually
non-intrusive because these systems up
to this point are were so extremely
intrusive to to solve it takes a few
months of time to just implement it in a
in in in in a typical file element code
sorry
the previous slide so those
the samples are dependent on time so
every time steps it exactly changing
that's right exactly because these are
without with a fixed sample you wouldn't
be able to do this and I'll show you
next in the demonstration that exactly
that's that's exactly right it is an
implementation of that it's
kind of
interested no well
you need to have access to the F right
hand side right so yeah right hand so
you can get it for example in the Fuller
model but the rows are rows are
intrusive because rows you actually need
to know the terms of the equation so
that's the part to know all the terms in
the governing equation and and that's
changing every time step so that's right
these rows and columns change every time
you stand it'll look at this SVD and
approximation of SVD of the previous
time is above F and based on that I'll
update this yes and this kind of
approximation like I said is quite
rigorous actually so instead of
approximating it basically we're
approximating the entire Matrix of f
with an F hat which is the cor
decomposition which is this uh approx
this multiplication of these two skinny
matrices you can show actually the
difference between the full Matrix and
this approximation in the second Norm is
so Sigma P1 if we were doing SVD here
this error would be exactly equal to
Sigma or P plus one this would be Plus
One Singular value here we only get this
scaling of of these two numbers so times
the optimal error that you can get with
the rank up rank or approximation and
dime procedure and these are the
condition number of the interpolation
matrices and dime procedure in fact is a
greedy procedure to minimize these two
numbers so you get really small numbers
for these two so you get that's what I
said you get actually something similar
to an SVD that's that's what I mean but
with that actually forming that Matrix
at all and and you can form and you can
make this number of sample points also
adaptive because
you can look at the last singular value
that you are resolving so divided you
can come up with different error error
criteria but you can look at the last
singular value divided by the summation
of the resolved singular value and if
that's not within the pound that you
want you can add which is sample F at
one more columns and one more rows
so let me show you some application uh
to uq so this is a stochastic various
equation the randomness comes from the
initial condition and the boundary
condition and we're using a spectral
element to solve this equation
uh and so you can see here the singular
values let me show you that because in
the interest of time I want to show you
the the speed up actually you get and
then I'll show you some of the error so
this is ttb ROM this is if you don't use
this kind of methodology
and this is how the CPU time scales as
you increase the number of grid points
so n is the number of grade points the
number of rows but this one actually
scales linearly
and so and also this is as you increase
the number of samples so as the number
of scales linearly again here
but and and young so when you ask the
the time points are time dependent and
that's exactly okay so we can use dime
or Q dime which is based on QR
decomposition and this is Burgers uh
with this with sharks so you see the
shot two shocks here and you can see
here that actually the down points are
changing with time this access is time
this is just I'm just showing the raw
points right so I'm not showing the
columns because there's a spot sampling
in the column as well as you can see the
Q Diamond dime actually capture almost
the same points uh so one one immediate
way you can see the advantage of this if
you go to the full or like the way we
were doing these things before we were
actually Computing the right hand side
that all of these grid points right now
we are only competing the right hand
side at these points so that's just that
just tells you one one quick way to to
see how efficient this is and here we
are comparing the modes that we extract
by doing this kind of approximation with
carbon and love approximation of the
full all which is the optimal based
instantaneous places and you can see we
have shock and we are capturing the
photo model really well
um
this is another example Vegas equation
has quadratic non-linearity maybe you
were able to do you can do that
intrusively and still get efficiency but
not even even you do it intrusively
you're not going to be as efficient as
this methodology but here this is a
compressible flow by the non-linearity
is non-polynomial so you have actually
rho U divided by row so you have
non-linearity of fractional
non-linearity and if with this guitarist
this system I have 262 000 rows and then
we have 200 000 samples so this is the
case if you want to do uq here you can
even store this Matrix in memory like we
we solve this in CPU and laptop CPU so
you can't even store this on the laptop
CPU so and we never actually during the
workflow we never store the full Matrix
and we only do this as for sampling and
you can here first we did it for a small
number of samples so we can actually do
error analysis so we did here for 200
samples and we show with this is for
sampling we recover so this is the tdb
ROM if you don't do sport sampling the
blue line but this is TDP ROM with six
Spar samples 20 and 20 spot samples this
is for Diamond Q diamond and cv20
samples you can actually recover almost
the ones that you don't do this for
sampling and like I said p is adaptive
so P changes in time so how many how
many samples you have for the right hand
side you can actually adaptively adjust
that to keep the error of this your
approximation below a given threshold
and you can see as time goes uh on the
actually get different numbers of P
so these are number of samples this is
actually when you say time dependent so
this is actually this is the mean and
the variance and you can see the sample
points actually captures the action here
where the action happens and like I said
this is now with 200 000 samples and
these are the samples in the column
space which you can see actually they
are located on the joint PDF of y1 and
Y2
and we did conversion study here by
increasing number of dying points and
you can see we are converging in the
instantaneous singular values by
increasing the rank of the system we are
still converging by increasing the
number of samples from 100 000 to 100
000 and navigation conversions all of
this is also in that paper all right I
think I'm almost out of time I'm already
ahead of time so let me just conclude
here and this is a
the way I I see this this field and the
contribution that this kind of reducer
modeling can do so if you look at the
way we were we are doing classical
scientific Computing we do separation of
variables we put time and the
coefficient and we choose the basis
right so you've got these spaces that
you can choose from that Library I think
another way of solving this equation
which is the structure resolving you
don't actually discretize the grade you
are actually capture the linear
non-linear correlation is by doing
physics inform neural network I know
policy is online
uh and basically you don't one way to
look at a physics inform neural network
is that you're not choosing the bases
you let the optimization process to find
the optimal places for you right so
there so that is another way to break
the cares of dimensionality and applying
this to high dimensional problems that's
why it's advantageous
this is also another way of doing that
but here we don't solve a non-linear
optimization problem right
um but like I said this has also its own
limitation but but you don't choose the
basis again from a library you let it
evolve with time and you the physics of
your equation and the residual of the
governing equation really determines
that so here we apply this to 2D problem
here this is compressible number so you
can see the basis actually evolves these
are bases in the one X2 Direction these
are bases in the X1 Direction and C
bases adaptively evolving time I mean
for this kind of problem it's not really
important to use these spaces but for
high dimensional problem this
localization and adaptivity of the basis
is really the key to break the cursive
dimensionality because you don't want to
put decrease of freedom in in places
especially in high dimensional spaces
you don't want to wear stickers of
freedom and so this can actually
effectively do that and we have applied
this to tensor Evolution equations as
well uh which I didn't have time to
cover that today a and maybe someone had
time yeah and so this is where I see the
place of this so it's actually it's got
good connections with classical
Computing and also with machine learning
in in a way because this is a low rank
approximation
all right so I'll with that I'll uh
thank you and I'll take any questions
wonderful wonderful thank you so much
handsome what a wonderful very
interesting
um
okay so let's have a q a session so we
do have a question from Pat Pat are you
online
yes hey okay yeah why don't you ask
questions directly
those were I really liked the the the
images and stuff that I think they they
really helped but I did have trouble
understanding what the what the reduced
submissions uh corresponded to what are
they what are they representing are they
for the in the chemical example for
example or uh you talked about having
lots of species a new uh the new basis
that's each one correspond to an
algebraic combination of the original
species or is it something else that's
right so every one of those let me go
back to that example that's exactly
right I think you said it at the end
that
so if you look at this Matrix as the
Matrix of of the oldest species we don't
solve for these directly we solve for
these modes each of these modes are
really a linear combination of all of
this species
okay this is yeah it's always linear
it is always linear but you can actually
extend this to uh non-linear answers as
well and that's actually what we're
working and and that is actually I think
the next really Frontier so so there
might be cases where some of the species
are effectively have to have no
influence at all
but and there's others where it's really
a mixture of them and my guess is
there's certain kinds of things that go
on there like you would probably never
have
um
my guess is that there would be the
species would be clustered or something
I I don't know if that's true but I can
imagine that being true absolutely
and that's exactly right so that's so
what you're talking about is actually
this is maybe not one Global time
dependent basis but you can actually
localize that either in the composition
especially in the physical space and I
have and absolutely so we are actually
exactly working on on that idea as well
uh and and and and and we see actually
amazing Improvement compared to just
using one on global I believe that I
believe it speeds things up I just want
to understand what's going on so these
are like the species are like gang
members they hang out together exactly
and they travel the same together and
and and and and so on okay got it thank
you of course great
then I had a second question about the
Cur work which seemed very different
so so in one example you showed some of
the points and it looked like those were
the points that had sort of the extreme
values
was that is that right that's right so
let me show the Berger's equation
exactly so
I think so what they actually these
points correspond to so they actually
concentrated over the shocks right so
they're two shocks here right so and and
the diamond algorithm in a clever way
actually picks out so you don't need to
sample this at all of the points here
you only need to sample it at these
points but this is usually where action
happens right so when I when I turn on
the Weather Channel and someone tells me
well there's a front moving through here
it's sort of like that you can you're
they're trying to identify the the
interesting the
discontinuities or or or
major change kind of kind of areas
in fact one thing you can immediately
see if you look at the dime procedure if
these are these are the two modes that
are visualized these are often normal
modes to each other and so the time the
first time point if I wanna the first
the most important point is where this
mode is has a maximum value
that's actually the first point which is
that is the if you want to pick one
point in your system at the inside of
time that has the most variance that's
this point here so he picks that one and
then it sort of recursively takes out
this mode out of the system and see
what's left within the leftover then it
starts in a greedy way to pick up more
points and it does that it's like it's
sort of like a QR type approximation use
layer by layer with each point you pick
out okay so they are will be
concentrated so you see these modes are
highly non-local highly localized right
so they are very localized near the shot
and in between they're sort of flat so
time doesn't actually pick those points
and it's uh it's a brilliant methodology
okay thank you very much of course
okay next question is from Mariam Mariam
online
yeah I am online okay you can ask uh
actually when I'm thinking to how extend
to what extent the metals could be used
it's come to my mind that what are the
exact uh conditions or requirement that
the pde should have to can be applicable
excellent question so remember when I
said the beginning these are Laurent
hyproximation for Matrix differential
equation number one you have to uh
formulate your problem as a matrix
differential equation one and then
second you need to see if that Matrix
instantaneously has low rank
if your problem meets these two criteria
then this is a really good method uh to
use if not that's not the end of the
story that's actually a topic of future
research
let me know if it doesn't make sense
the method is uh is mainly developed for
a Time dependent PDS if you have another
type of PDs that it's partial
differential but doesn't include the
time do you think it's applicable today
you can do it absolutely you can do that
for actually there are a lot of nice
results theoretical results for steady
state PDS so first of all this this time
iterations would become this time
Evolution becomes iterations in in that
context and you can you can take much
larger leap and steps to convert not
limited by the time so there are other
algorithms that you can use to jump over
that and then then you can show actually
converge to the SVD of that result so
there are a lot of nice things you can
show but yeah absolutely the you can
apply this to steady state problems
thank you
well following on Marion's questions you
know if you don't have a time dependent
times then instead you have a 3D this
your space short domain is 3D then you
can make them to Matrix equations by
decomposing each Dimension into
Infinity you there are I mean even a
one-dimensional equation can be turned
into a matrix differential equation so
it's really that's actually when you
have to be even so a 3D problem can
become a
in a number of ways can become a matrix
differential equation right so you can
take the 2D slab As One Direction yeah
X1 and X2 and X3 is another direction
right so that's or you can even do this
for the tensor Revolution equation which
I didn't talk about right so that's
another way so I have a 3D problem
naturally fits within a tensor Evolution
equation and sensor Evolution equation
of this system is very similar to what I
just presented all the principles are
the same and you can derive that but
like I said there are a number of ways
you can
so so for example if you have a 1D
example no time dependence how would you
make it Matrix equations
you have only one one variable you can
do domain decomposition and put them
next to each other that's one way
I see
interesting interesting okay so
um any other questions
from audience
no we actually hit the 11 o'clock you
know punctually
all right
medically
um well thank you so much Hassan for the
wonderful talk and
sounds like you have more topics to talk
about
um let's you know Reserve that for the
the second yes
yeah well let's thank our invited
speaker Hassan for the wonderful talk
and um yeah so thank you so much we
appreciate the opportunity to present
yeah I learned a lot and I I promise you
I'm going to look into this movie deeply
yeah exactly the stuff you do actually
this is very relevant very relevant yeah
very relevant absolutely yes
all right sounds good thank you so much
if you can share the uh the slide with
me that would be wonderful okay sure
absolutely you can do that yeah sure
absolutely
all right okay thank you very much all
right thank you bye-bye